hello everyone and welcome to a really
awesome day and an insane one in the uh
gold money asian rapid semi-finals it's
the second match and if you remember
from yesterday magnus won the
uh first match and now 11 levon needs to
win the second match to bounce back and
force tie brakes which is not an easy
feat against anyone
especially against the world champion
but
he will of course try it and this the
game we're showing now
is the second game of the blitz section
so
uh in the rapid section uh lavon was
able to win two games
and he was able to win the second match
magnus had a really awesome game three
he uh had a win but levon defended
really well and
magnus wasn't able to win that one and
then in the fourth game magnus had to
push
uh push uh very hard and in the end it
was levon who won that one
so then we go into the blitz section and
now who wins the blitz section
uh is the winner or they go into
armageddon levon with the first game of
the
blitz section with the white pieces and
now magnus has the white pieces and he
needs a win to force armageddon
otherwise it's levon in the finals and
it's a game over for magnus so let's see
what happens here and what magnus will
choose for his ultimate weapon to
force armageddon so magnus with the
white pieces
opens with e4 uh we have e5 knight to f3
knights to c6 and the bishop to c4 we
have bishop to c5 by levon
and i know what you're thinking is the
ultimate weapon finally
going to appear on the board but the
answer is no it is um
and we are not at that moment in time
just yet but it will happen
so here after bishop to c5 we have c3
going for the main line of the joker
piano we have knight to f6
uh d3 d6 bishop to g5 now nicely
developing
h6 challenging the bishop asking do you
want to capture do you want to go back
do you want to go back here maybe
so bishop to h4 and now a6 so this is
all very standard stuff we have knight
beat to d2
and bishop back to a7 uh the the usual
retreat as you don't want to be for and
uh
well the pawn expansions that are coming
to come with an attack on your bishop so
here we have castles by both players
magnus castles levon castles
uh and a4 now preventing b5 we have
knight the a5 now attacking the bishop
here
and bishop to a2 and now only now
g5 so black playing very actively here
we have bishop to g3
and now knight to h5 attacking the
bishop with some ideas of maybe even
advancing
with f5 and so on and here uh
there is a game and i think this is what
magnus was going for because uh levon
already had this position on the board
this year in the grand chester rapid uh
took place in paris against alireza
ferruja
and alireza played d4 in this position
that game ended in a draw but here
magnus prepared something else he played
he prepared b for for this occasion and
it is now
as of move 13 that we have a completely
new game
so let's see how levon deals with this
novelty magnus brought
in his uh bag of surprises we have ninth
captures and g3 first he eliminates this
bishop
we have h captures on g3 and now he
brings back the knight knight to c6 so
now
the knight is no longer stranded on the
edge of the board
now we have knight to h2 and now magnus
here
has to try something because he needs a
win in this game if he doesn't win
then it's live on to the finals uh we
have king the g7 you have to unpin
from this very nasty diagonal so king to
g7 now the f pawn can be pushed
and now magnus plays g4 so he's trying
to
uh prevent black from making any
breakthroughs and he wants to prepare
his own breakthrough with uh moves like
g3 and f4 which will be risky but he
knew that
uh when he decided to play such a line
we have queen to f6 polygon
now g3 f4 is coming we have knight to e7
and now king to g2 so improving the
position as much as possible before we
decide to go for the breakthrough
as well black also has a very strong
bishop here
so knight to g8 and only now f4 and this
is now
where the where where the fun really
starts uh levon of course captures this
with e
cap e captures on f4 and now not
recapturing right away there is no rush
because the f1 is pinned so just
d4 locking out to the dark square bishop
part of the game
we have knight back to e7 now uh and
knight to c4 by magnus we have d5 now
attacking the knight and the e4 pawn
here
and the magnus now advances the e pawn
all the way to e5 and attacks level
one's queen or
knights the e5 also made maybe a
playable move
uh but it's uh still very hard for
example d captures on e4 we're going to
play g captures black can even play g
characters and it's a really crazy
position but it should favor black
um uh regardless of what what white does
so instead after this d5 move we have e5
by magnus
now comes queen to c6 now threatening
not just to pick up the knight but to
pick up the knight with
check so b5 attacking the queen magnus
continues happily sacrificing material
we have eight captures eight captures
and now levon grabs the free pawn
so queen captures on b5 and only now
knight back to d2 so now this knight
might be able to
find his way back into the game via the
f3 square but it's still
hard to imagine where this knight is
really going
uh white might have some ideas of bishop
to b1 queen to c2 maybe you can do some
damage this way
uh but still magnus is banking
everything on you know just
being weird this game so here we have
knights the g6
and queen to c2 so shifting the bishop
over to this diagonal
we have bishop to e6 and now bishop to
b1 but
there is no real way to dislodge this
knight from g knight from g6
so this queen bishop battery it's hard
to say how how useful it will be
and here levon is simply so much better
he can
pretty much play anything and he will
win the game he decides to go for c5
but i will show you uh just a very cool
line or rather i'm not even going to
show it to you feel free to pause the
video here and try to find a really
awesome move that wins the game on the
spot for levon while i give you a couple
of seconds
so for those of you who are able to do
it congratulations on
figuring this out because it's really
just an incredible move
uh and for those of you who just want to
enjoy the show i know you were watching
queen to e2 check but that's not the one
bishop captures on d4
that's the one and then we're going to
follow it up with queen tate to check
with the bishop slicing all the way
through this diagonal
now the idea behind bishop captures on
d4 is that well
the the white rook is hanging here and
the white does not have time to capture
on a8 if white captures here then we
play queen to e to check and then white
very quickly gets checkmated you can't
block with the rook because we covered
that square twice
so we're going to play king h1 it
doesn't matter king h3 also leads the
checkmate f captures on g3 now we
threaten
queen captures an h2 checkmate and after
the knight moves we play
g2 with check we're gonna pick up the
rook so after the king moves we're just
gonna pick it up
uh and uh or rather we we don't even
have to pick it up we can just play g1
and go for a double check here check and
check uh and our queen is nicely
defended so this is uh
uh very much forced queen h3 and now
queen captures and g4 will be checkmate
so uh bishop captures on d4 is uh is a
really deadly move so white will not be
able to capture here
white will have to play something like c
captures on d4 but the only then we play
rook captures on a1 and now of course
it's completely winning for white
not only is your position completely
shattered
uh you are also down a lot of material
so yeah after this bishop to b1 move uh
we did not see bishop captures on d4 but
like i said this position is so good for
black you can literally play anything so
c5 by lev one
uh we have knight to d to f3 and now c
captures on d4
we have rook captures on a7 magnus
continues again happily sacrificing
material
rook captures and now knight captures on
d4 attacking the queen and the bishop
trying to somehow break through through
this position but
black's position is just so solid it
doesn't seem like
it can happen so queen to b6 and now
knight to f5 with check hoping for
captures and captures to improve his
position a little bit
but leveling just goes back king to h8
we have knight to f3
and now uh f captures on g3 by levon
uh we have rooked the h1 now finally
getting some counter play
uh maybe levon allowed a bit too much
with that captures
but uh what are you gonna do it's a
blitz game you don't have all the time
in the world
uh but now just queen to have to check
he forces queen
a queen trade and then the attack is
over so here we have queen captures g
captures king captures and now uh rook
to a1 uh
saying uh wha what are you going to do
here so rook captures on h6 this is of
course
a must but not not really the rook can
actually remain on h1 and you could also
capture with the knight and threaten
some nasty discoveries
but magnus decides to capture with the
rook we have king the g8
and now he just moves his bishop so
bishop to d3
but now rook to c8 and here uh
although you have a lot of pieces uh
next to the next to the black king
uh there's really not all that much you
can do
even if you had uh like even if you had
a few moves
that you can make in a row there is
really really no thread that you can
make and black is just
black is just up material and in a much
better position so here
knight 5 to d4 was played but now we
have knight to f4
uh and here we have bishop to f5 uh
sorry bishop to f5 going after the dark
square bishop
but now just the rook captures on c3 by
levon he was in this position
on move 39 that magnus carlsen resigned
to the game
which means uh levon won both blitz
games after winning two rapid games and
which makes him the winner of the entire
match and it will be levon in the finals
facing off against uh i will not mention
who because i will also cover that in
this
in the next video that i make but the
next match is was also
so such a crazy one that uh i'm gonna
try and cover more than one game uh but
we'll see how it goes but really really
an incredible one and i think we're
gonna have an awesome final match
so uh levon uh came into this match uh
with a loss but then he was able to
bounce back and win
tie breaks so that's really really
incredible and a huge congratulations to
him
so here you resign because there's uh
really not all that
much you can do there's no threat that
you can make and pretty much
just anything that black does is is
winning you can just push this pawn to
victory that's also just winning okay
you can't just blunder it but uh there's
not much that you can do here
uh there there's not even a move that
for example knight captures on g5 you
could
uh grab a pawn and get another piece in
front of the black king we can we can
just trade here bishop captures on f5
and now if g captures
i just rooked a to check and we've
eliminated all that we needed to
successfully check made the white king
uh so
yeah not much to be done there okay king
f1 rook to c1
will be checkmate or bla white can you
know be
uh defending a little bit better but
it's still going to end in checkmate
very very quickly
so magnus of course uh knows this and
after rook captures on c3 he resigned
the game yeah there you have it uh
brutal semi-final match between magnus
carlson and eleven are young
uh and uh well in indian levon prevails
and
what uh what uh what a huge victory for
him uh so we'll see what happens in the
finals
but the next match that we're covering
is also incredibly
satisfying to watch so stay tuned uh so
yeah
that's the game hope you guys enjoyed it
i would like to thank constantino buchi
uh vladolaro lucas de ocaris melanie
peters and david pierce for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot to really appreciate it
as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon
continuing the coverage of this very
nice event checking up on your wonderful
suggestions
and whatever else happens uh in the
chess world thank you all i will see you
soon and have an excellent rest of your
day